pas c'est Sylvain Auger qui va nous
rejoindre ce soir Sylvain Auger qui est
l'invité du PAF personnalité
emblématique de la télévision des années
90 il en a animé des émissions notamment
la carte au trésor faut pas rêver il va
se livrer Sylvain au gîte le fait dans
un livre qui va sortir le 12 octobre il
parle de sa vie bonjour Sylvain on est
très heureux de vous recevoir sur ce
plateau merci beaucoup merci d'être là
moi j'étais très touchée par votre livre
qui sont le 11 octobre très touché parce
que vous vous livrez parce que vous vous
livrez vous parlez en vérité de ce mal
que vous avez découvert assez tard et
vous parlez de cette vie assez
exceptionnelle que vous avez eu à
travers vos différentes émissions mais
pas que mais pas que Sylvain Augier
parce que parce que vous étiez un
sportif vous avez besoin d'aller toucher
vos limites d'aller toucher les limites
en permanence
j'aime bien les exploits les sports
spectaculaires et puis un jour j'ai été
frappé par une maladie qui s'appelle la
maladie bipolaire dont on va pouvoir
parler qui a été comme un coup de
tonnerre dans un ciel bleu et d'un seul
coup il a fallu que je me soigne que je
guérisse mais j'en sors la preuve se
livre que j'appelle volontairement je
reviens de loin parce qu'on peut en
revenir on peut se guérir et en soigner
voilà vous l'avez découvert l'âge de 35
ans c'est ça
raconter au téléspectateurs qui n'ont
pas lu votre livre moi je racontais j'ai
passé une semaine extraordinaire
l'arrivée de la Route du Rhum en
1990 que je dis pas de bêtises que
Florence arthaut a gagné ça m'a donné
une surexcitation absolument anormale
une folie circulaire comme on dit j'ai
loué des avions des bateaux j'ai emmené
tout le monde se promener
vous dépensez de l'argent sans compter
vous dites dans le livre jusqu'à même
mes propres limites oui jusqu'à ce que
j'en ai plus jusqu'à ce que vous en ayez
plus pour profiter voilà alors je
profite à fond je suis heureux comme un
roi et puis je rentre à Paris et à Paris
subitement après une émission de radio
en direct je suis frappé par une
dépression violente suicidaire et je me
suis dit que j'allais pas en sortir et
mon aventure a commencé là parce que le
psychiatre que j'ai appelé et rejoint à
Paris très vite bah 10 c'est une maladie
de bipolaire de type 1 ça ne se guérit
pas on ne peut pas en guérir c'est comme
ça mais en revanche on peut le soigner
en fait c'est ça a commencé par une
phase maniaque genre énorme et puis
ensuite c'est la phase descendante en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelait avant la
maniaco-dépressif donc on a des phases
d'espèces de forêt il y a pas mal de
personnalités qui ont avoué enfin avoué
enfin parler du polarité genre par
exemple Britney Spears par exemple on la
voit sur les réseaux sociaux de temps en
temps qui tourne comme ça comme une
espèce de toupie le derbiche tourneur
comme ça donc face maniaque et puis des
moments voilà où elle est complètement
dingue et c'est effectivement certaines
maladies et certains types de cette
maladie peuvent se stabiliser avec des
médicaments je sais pas comment vous
êtes traité mais moi j'ai des amis
proches de moi qui sont au lithium c'est
compliqué aussi le traitement c'est
assez lourd enfin ça prend du temps de
trouver le bon traitement de bon dosage
il y a des gens célèbres qui ont été
atteint par la maladie vipère Churchill
Hemingway et Margot sa petite fille ils
sont suicidé tous les deux parce que
c'est le grand danger de Virgin
de maladie bipolaire c'est quand on est
en dépression c'est suicidaire et on
pense qu'à une chose c'est disparaît
donc sinon on va parler de ça parce que
vous dites dans le livre vous avez fait
une espèce de tentative de suicide avec
le TGV on y reviendra dans un instant
mais je voudrais savoir d'abord est-ce
que vous savez ce qu'il y a déclenché la
maladie et comment vous avez réagi quand
le diagnostic est tombé alors c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est la génétique mon
père était bipolaire mon grand-père
était bipolaire j'ai hérité de ça plein
pot au maximum on l'a découvert qu'à 35
ans ça aurait pu être un peu avant ou un
peu après mais toujours est-il que
c'était à ce moment-là et sinon vous me
disiez quoi et comment vous avez réagi
quand le diagnostic tombe et qu'on vous
dit vous êtes bipolaire il va falloir
vous traiter catastropher je me suis dit
que j'allais pas en sortir et d'où sa
TGV en face duquel je me suis mis en me
disant de nouveau en finir tout de suite
quoi il faut se débarrasser de cette
souffrance électro difficile à soutenir
mais j'ai des enfants adorables et pour
eux je ne l'ai pas fait
je vais vous expliquer que le TGV passe
vraiment à quelques centimètres de vous
vous sentez le souffle de ce TGV qui
peut vous happer et vous résistez vous
résister parce que vous pensez aux vôtre
en fait oui je pense à ce que j'aime ce
qui est terrible dans le suicide c'est
que c'est la fin de votre souffrance
vous qui voulez disparaître mais c'est
le début de la souffrance des autres et
quand on aime d'autres personnes dans le
monde que je pense à mes enfants bien
sûr et à ma femme je pouvais pas leur
faire ça quoi c'est impossible c'était
trop dur c'était trop dur on voit
effectivement une des citations du livre
je reviens de loin qui sort le 12
octobre et c'est dans dans ce contexte
donc vous continuez à présenter et
animer ces émissions télé qu'on connaît
tous évidemment tous notamment je cite
que la carte au trésor mais vous en avez
tellement il faut pas rêver bien sûr
aventurier des temps modernes à la
télévision quand même plus de près de
100 émissions de de la carte au trésor
gros carton d'audience vous incarnez le
monsieur aventure de la télévision
française j'ai pris le relais de
Philippe de Dieu
positionner d'hélicoptère et vous tombez
dans une émission avec des hélicoptères
quand j'ai eu un accident de parapente à
33 ans je m'étais fait trois voeux à
l'hôpital le 1er c'était de remarcher
normalement au lieu d'être amputé et ce
qui a été le cas je me suis battu pour
ça le second c'était revenir à la
télévision si elle est dans le parieur
et j'ai pas arrêté pendant 10 ans donc
comme vous le disiez et puis devenir
pilote d'hélico il est jeune il a
dynamique il a une bonne dégaine il est
sympa quoi je trouve qu'il avait un peu
de relais c'était pas évident c'est le
meilleur des successeurs que vous
pouviez avoir oui je prends je crois
sincèrement je crois que il est bien sa
place là et les audiences sont au
rendez-vous tout comme vos émissions
avant que vous n'arrêtiez la carte du
président
effectivement dans les années 90 ils
sont pas les mêmes aujourd'hui que que
combien vous faisiez en audience en
moyenne la carte au trésor c'est manger
4 millions de personnes 4 millions de
personnes à peu près à peu près environ
25% de parts de marché quoi on va dire
25% sur les sur la cible jeune notamment
ça a donné envie à plein de jeunes de
notre génération des années 90 2000 à
vous suivre dans des aventures disons de
rêves
c'est un vrai réalisé je fais ce métier
de 40 ans et ça reste un rêve
d'adolescent qui se réalise chaque jour
un peu plus avec vous là maintenant que
la télé est-ce que ça vous manque de
présenter ou d'animer ce type d'émission
non
[Musique]
j'ai admiré que quand vous connaissez
bien tous et Michel Drucker pour
travailler pour lui j'ai
œuvré pour lui j'ai fait ce temps
parachute au-dessus de Paris avec
Belmondo j'ai créé la France judiciaire
pour lui pour le lui faire plaisir
regardez on vous voit avec Michel
Drucker devant un hélicoptère est-ce
vous vous souvenez de cet instant de
cette faute
de la photo racontez-nous
chez Pierre Perret si je me souviens
bien mais comme ça pour une émission
c'est comme ça
et en même temps vu les embouteillages à
Paris c'est pratique c'est pratique ah
oui c'est ça c'était combien de temps
cette photo vous vous souvenez à peu
près oh il y a 10 ans facile mais ça ne
ment pas ça non puisque ça parce que
quand on voit la tête de Drucker il a
l'air tout jeune là dessus non s'il y a
pas plus que ça et puis on avait pas le
droit on avait pas le droit de
passer en hélico au dessus de Paris
aussi et puis un certain temps donc à
mon avis c'était avant d'accord
je sais que ça fait un moment tu peux
pas passer
[Musique]
de la préfecture
c'est important de préciser vous avez
des souvenirs incroyables des souvenirs
de moments incroyables peut-être dans la
carte au trésor qui vous reviennent
comme ça est-ce que vous avez des
moments d'émotion ou des moments de peur
tout simplement dans cette inquiétudes
pour mes candidats qui se baladaient qui
allaient pas forcément au bon endroit ou
qu'elle allait se faire charger par un
taureau furieux on a des anecdotes à
l'appeler
un plaisir fou à faire cette émission
j'imagine parce que c'était voilà c'est
une mission un peu en roue libre et
d'aventure etc donc à l'intérieur
et en 2006 vous êtes écartés de France 3
soit disant parce que vous aviez du mal
à vous remettre d'un accident de moto
c'est vrai cette histoire j'ai eu un
accident de moto en Corse mais je suis
pas sûr que ça soit à cause de
l'accident de moto qu'on met écarté
quelle est la vraie raison selon vous
j'en sais rien vraiment oui
je sais pas mais comment vous a dit bon
maintenant c'est terminé comment vous
annoncé que c'était terminé que voilà un
déjeuner ou le responsable des
programmes de France 3 qui venait d'être
nommé m'a annoncé pour changer de
formule et qu'on a arrêté la carte au
trésor qui est difficile vous vous y
attendiez ou pas non pas du tout comment
vous savez je suis resté un adolescent
naïf c'est ma chance
c'est un milieu qui est pas évident
c'est déjà vous avez eu un déjeuner
c'est déjà pas mal parce que parfois il
y a même pas le déjeuner
il faut bien regarder en tête tout le
temps et se dire profitons pendant que
nous sommes là est-ce que vous avez ici
rapidement de rebondir sur une autre
chaîne de faire autre chose audiovisuel
même en tant que producteur oui je
rebondis j'ai eu envie de filmer
l'Europe et on est parti pour filmer
l'Europe à trois en hélicoptère on est
parti pendant deux mois et demi trois
mois et on a ramené des images de
l'Europe qui continuent à se vendre en
Europe un peu partout sur les chaînes
internationale tout à fait vous avez une
banque d'image de données que vous
pouvez vendre par exemple pour des
documentaires ou des choses comme ça que
vous avez fait c'est ça
et l'Europe du ciel personne de l'avait
fait donc comme la France vue du ciel
personne l'avait fait avant moi donc
j'ai profité du vide qui était laissé et
vous étiez un aventurier formidable en
88 vous avez eu un accident de parapente
ou franchement vous auriez pu y rester
la voile c'est fermé j'étais en vol à
2000 mètres d'altitude la moitié de la
voile s'est fermée elle est partie en
tourbillonnant et quand j'ai touché le
sol une panthère beuse heureusement et
pas des rochers mon pied s'est détaché
de ma jambe et il pendait au bout de mon
artère quoi et j'avais tout le bras et
l'épaule ce quartier quoi donc des
dizaine d'opérations des mois
d'hospitalisation de rééducation j'en ai
bavé ça a été dur mais tout ce qui nous
dit pas nous en plus fort ça m'a rendu
plus fort vous avez bien raison bien sûr
que ça vous a rendu plus fort évidemment
et puis vous avez frôlé la mort dans
tous les ports les sports extrêmes que
vous avez pratiqué parce que vous avez
tout fait hein
vous avez touché à tous il va Roger tout
ce qui va vite et tout ce qu'il procure
des sensations fortes oui c'était des
rêves de gosse que je réalisais
vous vous gérez ça est-ce que vous avez
toujours besoin de ces sensations fortes
non je dois donner beaucoup plus calme
je passais
le fait d'écrire ma canaliser
je reçois des écrivains là où j'habite à
côté de Sommières à côté de Nîmes j'aime
bien les faire parler et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas moi quoi mais oui mais
c'est une excellente idée vous savez que
je suis libre voilà d'où ce livre qu'on
vous recommande les téléspectateurs de
pas font des questions à vous poser
c'est des questions du PAF
voilà les premières questions de Julien
moi je la trouve bien cette question
Julien si vous aviez présenter une
émission aujourd'hui ce sera laquelle
à quelle bonne question
de aéronautique à l'image de Thalassa
pour la mer on avait créé Pégase avec
France 3 Bordeaux et France 3 et
j'aimerais bien me relancer là dedans
parce que la matière j'aime bien tout ce
qu'ils veulent quoi
merci beaucoup merci infiniment sur
je reviens de
loin c'est c'est plein d'espoir voilà
pour peut-être tous ceux qui souffrent
de la de cette maladie de la bipolarité
effectivement on s'en sort et on arrive
à la cannelle
de personnes qui souffrent de la
bipolarité en France et il y a 8000
suicides par an j'ai voulu que mon livre
soit utile à ceux qui souffre de ça
voilà